[Musique]
jagger sont pas moins
or un braqueur bon premier jeu de mots
après le jeu on pousse sur le coude avec
un coup de pouce là j'ai prise sur
l'endroit de brad pitt et là j'ai un
oeuf au plat sur le mollet dont neuf
mois les durs tu vois ravi toi moi je
suis toujours d'accord mais étudie
encore un peu plus
tu veux faire quoi là bientôt là bientôt
je n'en mets comme tatouage à coop
tatouage voyager perton sur le pied pour
faire un piéton ah ouais
[Musique]
la
crise
avec ça
[Musique]
il ya toujours un conte qui se met
devant de paris au caire à trois lames
couchepin garde bonjour je sais qu'il
faut aller
[Rires]
[Musique]
bonjour zz de mieux nous verrons il vous
vous êtes qui je suis un peu sur le
jazzman mais un peu 2 décembre on sort
ah ah ah
[Rires]